Hẹn gặp tổng tháng 2 phát bí hợp tạng hội đồng nhiên quên lửa hợp ở trên này và ngoài trường của ba ông
Bruno Rudegate, gặp bộm đi đi đàn tìm gắt người ra một tham hoàn yên đào, thông qua các biện phát phòng trỏ
năng lượng đối với đồng của này.
Yêu thấy Rudegate chỉ trích sắc lệnh hành pháp ngày hẹn gặp chỉ tham một quả tổng thống
mình là hành động trưng phát tập thể nhằm bằng người dân của ba, đồng thời đặc co hỏi liệu một
cường quốc có thể hủy giết phố cuo dả nhỏ và hoa bình.
Dời dành ý hãi an nền của giá hay không, ông cho rằng trực phố tế hình thành sau thị trình
hại đảng bị sỏi món. Nhà ngoài rau của ba khẳng định là ha bà năng sẽ bảo vệ
chủ quyền và quyền thực quyết, đồng thời sẵn sẵn sẵn đối thoại về Washington, trên
cơ sở mình đồng và lợp pháp của tế. Ông Nhân Mạnh, phố ba có đất cạnh tác,
tạnh quyền nước, khoảng sản, năng lực lọc dầu và đam đẩy mạnh đồng từ năng lượng mặt chơi.